so yes I'm NIC O'Leary I'm a developer
advocate at IBM working the Watson IOT
area in a previous life I worked in I'm
merging technologies group and whilst I
was there I created something called
node-red so a quick survey who has not
heard of node-red ok enough you great
who has actually used node-red played
with it tried it out has opinions about
it
excellent so this talk is going to be a
bit of a mix of introducing what no
dreads about where it's come from what
it does and then look at what we're
doing with a moment what others in the
community have been doing with it we've
got some really nice examples of how
companies have started adopting it and
using it in real you know productive
scenarios and then we're gonna look at
some of our roadmap for the project as
we move forward through the rest of this
year and into early next year yeah
everything we've got planned for the
project so what is no dread no dread is
a developer tool that helps you create
IOT style applications and an IOT style
application is effectively an
event-driven one creating flow based
programs that all designed around the
idea of something happens and you want
to react and how can you in a graphical
environment describe what you want it to
do when that something happens and
that's well suited to IOT it's well
suited to many different domains but for
where we were working the sort of client
problems we were working on in 2013 when
we started the project it was very much
about IOT type scenarios raspberry pies
with sensors attached
how can you gather that data do
something interesting with it and pass
it on and in those sorts of projects we
were doing in emerging technologies we'd
do like one or two we'd proof of
concepts across the whole range of
different technology areas we still
realized the number of times we're
writing code in whatever language it
might be to access the serial port
because there's a GPS attached or to
authenticate with an online API like
Twitter yeah that's just boilerplate
code and
time we spent writing that code is not
time we're being productive actually
creating the value of a solution we want
to build that along with just wanting to
play with technology and you think about
well how can how can use tackle this
problem to make a developer tool that's
very visual and also accessible to a
wide range of developers whether it's
you know people like many of us in the
room who has no problem getting down
into those individual lines of code if
you have to but you know if there's a
tool that makes that easier than all
that's great to another extreme or you
know kids who want to get started or
people who have moved away from a
development role and want to get back
into it but you know haven't you know
don't know JavaScript or don't know
whatever the current flavor of favorite
toolkit happens to be and yeah it's it's
a slightly sort of these weren't the
thoughts that started the project but
looking back and reflecting on where
we've got to we think of node-red
in terms of like the office suite of
applications that if you want to work
with words you use word processor if
you're working with numbers you use a
spreadsheet and if you're working with
ideas you can use PowerPoint or your
presentation software but each of those
tools is accessible to someone who's
just writing you know a thank you letter
to their grandmother someone who's just
doing their weekly shopping list
all the way to someone who understands
Excel macros and all the really crazy
stuff you can do in Excel but it's a
tool that's accessible to a really broad
range of people so it's that thought of
well what's the equivalent tool when you
want to create applications that's
working with events yeah IOT being all
about an event-driven system whether
it's sense the data whether it's social
media whether it's weather data whatever
it might be how can you create tools
that help you just explore those sorts
of problems and then just as someone who
likes to play with technology and make
lights light up and things go ping how
can you have tooling that just helps you
scratch that itch over yeah well when I
notice that thing
over there happening maybe to begin with
I just want to alert someone that that's
happened but actually maybe the next
thing I'm to do is actually kick off
this whole business process or maybe I
just want this Arduino to ring a bell or
whatever it might be and having a tool
that can make it really easy to build
those applications and iterate and and
play so for those who have not seen it
when you run node-red it's a node.js
application you point your web browser
at it and you get the node-red editor so
down this left hand side are all the
nodes and each node represents some sort
of capability and you drag into the
workspace so there I've dragged in a
Twitter node which knows how to
authenticate with Twitter and it's
looking for all tweets that mention the
starwars hashtag wide it to a debug node
and that you can see in the debug
sidebar there tweets from Twitter at the
mention Star Wars Isis I recorded this
demo on the day the force awakens came
out so there was a nice stream of safe
tweets a previous version was on the day
of the Scottish independence referendum
in the UK and it was not safe to show
the tweets in a public setting such as
such as yeah such as politics but here
we go I've dragged on a [ __ ] database
node and all I've done is configured it
to point out a [ __ ] instance running on
my laptop dragged that wire and those
tweets are now being saved in a
collection on [ __ ] without having
written any code so it's not just about
you know capturing tweets of social
media you can also start creating rest
api's web pages served up by node-red
so here of configure [ __ ] query node
pointed at the same collection that's
just going to collect bring back all the
records from from the collection and
then HTTP input node so that's going to
start listening on slash tweets and
weddings on a web browser that goes to
slash tweets it will trigger this flow
you'll look up all the tweets in the
database and then a template node which
uses mustache just hurry up me and paste
it in there we go just a little simple
bit of HTML crater and
list of all the text all those tweets I
hit deploy and I now go to slash tweets
and there are all those tweets that were
in the database so no code written but
you know I'm capturing data presenting
it on a web page and that's what
node-red is there for to help you you
know think of a problem start solving it
really quickly and start iterating very
quickly over how you want to approach
the problem how you may want to solve it
so what is a node read flow so node read
is an embodiment of flow-based
programming this idea as it turns out
invented by IBM in the early 1970s about
creating applications that are these
networks of asynchronous processes
essentially these little black boxes
that don't know who they're connected to
but they will just be given some data
they'll do some work and they'll spit
some data out the other end and the
system takes care of passing the data
between these black boxes and that sort
of abstraction is really powerful for
creating a system where each of these
black boxes is you know it does one job
and it does it very well and you know
through convention in the platform it
knows how it's receiving data and it
will just do its job and pass it on and
that turns out to be quite a powerful
way to tackle programming problems where
if you understand a problem or if you
know what you want to achieve say I want
to get a web page that displays all the
tweets that mention Star Wars you can
start breaking that down into individual
steps you can think well that means I
need to somehow access the Twitter API
and get some tweets well okay that's a
Twitter node for querying the Twitter
API and well I probably need to store
them so a [ __ ] database know to start
storing them and then a webpage so
create HTTP input flow to trigger when
someone access the webpage the query
know to get the data a template node to
render it and a response node to reply
it helps someone who perhaps doesn't
appreciate the individual lines of code
that all of that takes it gives them
that high level of abstraction so you
understand well the
the nodes I need and I should start
wiring together the messages that pass
from node to node are just JavaScript
objects and it isn't a strongly type
system it is very loosely typed on
purpose but by convention each of the
messages has a payload property and
that's where we say the interesting
information goes for each node so the
Twitter node will put the text 140
characters of the tweet in the payload
property for so historical reasons a lot
of messages will also have a topic
property that's described sort of
metadata about what that message is
about and that reflects near the very
early days and heritage of node read
which was more focused on mapping
messages in a mqtt messaging environment
so that's convention but it is a
JavaScript object so nodes are free to
attach whatever other properties they
want whatever make sense so in fact the
Twitter node also includes a tweet
property and that contains the full
JavaScript object that the Twitter API
returns and it's always impressive how
many kilobytes of metadata it takes to
share 140 characters but it's there for
you to access and use but the fact that
the interesting information is in
payload means a lot of the nodes can
just be strung together and they just
work the manga database node knows just
to store payload as the object in the
database the sentiment analysis node we
have which does very simple looks each
word in the payload and it has a big
dictionary of positive and negative
scores for each word so it can take a
tweet that says Jedi are totally amazing
in the payload it doesn't modify the
payload but it does add this additional
property sentiment with a positive or
negative number based on that sentiment
score so going back to this bit of the
video what we're going to do is exactly
I just described put in a sentiment bit
of sentiment analysis and do a better
job of presenting those tweets so we
have a function node that lets you
actually write some JavaScript if you're
itching to write some JavaScript that
will get run against the messages
as they flow through and in this
instance taking advantage of the fact we
can attach whatever properties we want
I'm attaching a message sort and a
message limit pair of properties because
those are properties the manga query
node will react to and respond to so
there I've just modified the flow so it
gives the five most recent tweets rather
than the entire collection this is
unedited real-time but I do wish I had
slightly edited it because there's a bit
of a love at the moment first I think
about what I'm doing next so at this
point we're going to add in some
sentiment analysis on the tweets so as I
said we have a very simple sentiment
analysis node doesn't need any
configuration it just knows to look at
payload and and do its thing on there so
we drag that into the flow and we're
gonna add in another function node and
here I'm copying off a off-screen buffer
so I don't have to write code in front
of you which looks at the sentiment
score if it's greater than 0 or less
than zero it attaches another property
with the text positive or negative and
now I'm going to replace the template
with a bit more HTML and CSS and yeah as
is inevitable with programming I
probably spent more time on the CSS in
this demo than I did recording this
video but when I hit deploy and I
refresh that page those five remaining
tweets now look like tweets but note
they've got the color sidebar which is
based on the sentiment of that text so
with I'd say no code written or very
little amount of code written that's
what I've cheated with no dread in under
five minutes
so these flows are great but what's
actually doing under the covers so when
you hit the deploy button when if you
make a change and the the deploy button
goes red up in the top corner and you
hit that the editor sends back to the
runtime some Jason and that Jason is
your node red flow and it's the it's
essentially an array of objects which
are the nodes and how each of those
nodes is configured and how they're
wired together so node red isn't doing
code generation you know that Jason is
the artifacts that is your node-red
application but that's really useful
because this is Jason I can copy and
import your paste I can drag and drop
javascript files straight into the node
editor sorry Jason files straight in the
node editor to import those flows so
that makes it really quick and easy to
share flows to collaborate with others
you know that is the artifact that there
is a node read flow the nodes themselves
so all the nodes are node modules and
you know if I went back the clock I
would
we've overloaded the term node because
we have nodes and node read that had
node modules and they run in no jet yet
you sort of get blind to it when you say
node
too many times but the nodes are node
modules and they consist of two files a
JavaScript file as you'd expect from a
node module which is the runtime
behavior of that node but also an HTML
file which is what gets loaded into the
editor and that just defines the
appearance of the node it's edit dialog
help text basically all the stuff you
need in the editor but it's just those
two files is what defines each of those
nodes in the palette they then get
packaged up with a package.json entirely
as you would expect but with some key
additional metadata there's a node read
section that describes the way which
defines what are the nodes that this
node module exposes and once that's been
published with a keyword of node-red
we've got an online library that every
10 minutes looks for nodes in npm that
or modules an NPM with the node-red
keyword and we index them in the
node-red library and as overcut weeks
ago we have over a thousand third-party
nodes or node modules available in node
read so these are you know that's a
thousand that you know us in the core of
node red have had actually nothing to do
with that individuals companies people
in the community who've started
self-publishing but that's really that's
really useful because it means with node
read often there's already at least one
node yeah as with NPM there's
least one node that does what you're
trying to do but they are rule
open-sourced and you know many are very
well maintained and you know accept full
requests and feature enhancements we do
try and discourage that proliferation of
well that node doesn't quite do what I
want so I've cloned it and created a
carbon copy of it but it's got one extra
feature yeah we within the community we
you know we try and work with the node
authors to minimize that proliferation
because that doesn't help users who you
know trying to keep that ease of use for
people who we don't want our users to
have to go to get up repositories to
understand the stuff of differences
between the different modules but we
don't do any active policing of the node
library we've got some basic quality
control we do before they'll appear in
in the library but that's very simple
things like it's got how to read me and
the readme has got to be at least a few
words and some other basic checks but
anyone is free to publish into the
library you'll see there's also a couple
of green boxes in that screenshot so
people can also share example flows in
the node-red library and you know share
useful things they're built with no
dread in there one of the examples of
the what was originally a third-party
contributed node set was what was
contribute it's now been adopted by us
in the main project node-red dashboard
so this is a set of nodes you can wire
into your flows that then ultimately
generate a fairly opinionated in
appearance dashboard at on a sort of /ui
URL and that's really useful for when
you want to create some quick
visualization of data because you can
flow you know sensor data straight into
a gauge node or straight into a chart
you can have a dashboard with buttons
and controls on it to get feedback going
the other way so as long as you don't
mind the opinionated angular one point
whatever dashboard then
it's there to create interactive
dashboards for your data the joke used
to be you can have it in any color as
long as it's our light or dark theme I'm
fortunate that jokes being ruined
because you can now customize the themes
to your own content as well but it
doesn't stop me telling you about the
joke I used to be able to tell so yeah I
say you can drag on those nodes the
layout is again fairly opinionated it
works on a this sort of auto flowing
group layout but you can have sliders
that you know as you change them those
sliders are wired up to those various
other gauges the stuff changes and yeah
so that's no dry dashboard again another
useful tool for really rapidly creating
interesting things when they'd read of
course this is all open source
we started node red in September 2013 at
the beginning of the year and you've got
we were using it within a month in real
client projects the sort of things we
were doing in emerging technologies and
we realized you know the best way
forward was to develop this as an open
source project because as has been
demonstrated the strength is the breadth
of capability in the pallet and as much
as we enjoy working on the core of node
red we don't have the time and bandwidth
to create a node for everything that a
node might want to be created for so it
was a very conscious decision from art
from our perspective from the start to
develop this as an open source project
and in September 2013 that's what we
were able to do and get the the
approvals from IBM and we've been
running as an open source project ever
since through till October last year
when we moved to the JavaScript
Foundation and were one the founding
projects of the J's foundation so that's
been a key step for the project the fact
you as much as we working on the project
would say no doubt is fully open source
yes there for anyone to consume and get
involved yeah it's always gets a bit
interesting when you get our fee by well
it's not really open source it's it's an
IBM project but yeah
just inherently not true because we are
on github we are accepting pull requests
and yeah we are an open community but
that moves did the JavaScript foundation
really provides that validation that we
are here for the community to get
involved at any level whether it's
individuals want to get involved or
companies who want to get more closely
involved so yeah really positive step
for our project because we run on nodejs
as I'm sure won't be shocking news to
anyone here we work we can run wherever
you can run though yes whether that's on
a Raspberry Pi on devices at the edge
all the way through to cloud platforms
such as IBM bluemix or wherever you
choose to run it and that's really
interesting capability when you've got a
common development platform like
node-red that can run on devices and can
run in the cloud more interesting for us
was knowing some of the people in the
Raspberry Pi foundation since November a
couple of years ago node-red is now
included on the default raspbian install
image on the Raspberry Pi and that's
opened us up to a whole new audience of
users both in so educational settings
and sort of hobbyist communities the
fact anyone who's get told her Russia
Pie node-red is already there
pre-installed in bluemix we are in the
bluemix catalog is one of the
boilerplate example applications so if
you've signed up to bluemix for your
30-day free trial you can get yourself a
node red instance running in a couple of
minutes and the version we stick up on
bluemix comes pre-installed with a bunch
of interesting nodes for the bluemix
services such as the watts and cognitive
services so visual recognition natural
language conversation whatever it might
be and we also have nodes for a lot of
the database services and just you know
an ever-growing set of things within the
catalog what's new this week and I
accepted the merge the pull request this
morning but later this week we're also
going to be integrating node app metrics
so this is another open source project
from IBM that in a couple of line
code automatically generates a live
dashboard
alongside your app that you can use to
monitor the performance of your app CPU
environmental data HTTP requests through
personal that good stuff so this is a
feature we're going to be adding to the
bluemix version hidden behind an
environment variable so it's something
once you've installed you will enable
but yeah that's a really cool project
and I encourage you guys to go have a
look at that this week and I say didn't
quite get it deployed in time for me to
say as of now but once I finished
talking I finished deploying it the
bluemix version will have that there and
there are other people and the great
thing that no dread is other people are
adopting it isn't just an IBM gig so
there are other companies who provide
host of node-red services read connect
IO a UK retail services company who
provide who use node-red to provide
solutions for their clients sense
technic provide a host of node-red
environment and AT&T provide their flow
designer which is a host of node-red
environment that's in the cloud on
devices we're seeing more and more
commercial vendors actually embed
node-red
in devices so multitec opted 22 Intel
and a whole bunch of others in your
ever-growing list including node-red
on their devices as the end user
configuration for those devices so of
course it gets interesting when you know
you've got node-red running on raspberry
PI's connecting to a platform like the
Watson IOT platform connecting to
applications running in the cloud such
as in bluemix which can then talk to all
the other services and giving that
common development environment that can
put an application in the cloud or on a
device all using flow-based programming
so i'm going to attempt a demo let me
check my raspberry pi still has an IP
address my roaming data from the UK is
slowly eating its way through but I'm
sure it won't be too expense
so this is a very quick demo of what you
can build with no dread when you're
talking about spanning a flow that runs
on a device and runs in the cloud so
it's a slack bot that can control a
Raspberry Pi here is a browse through
pipe and it's got the sense hat on top
which is this big bright LED screen and
we're going to create a little chat bot
that lets me have a conversation with
someone on slack to control this this
screen and believe me it's not John that
I'm chatting with in the back
controlling it remotely it is real so
I'm gonna whip through this we'll get
this written up and the slide shared if
you want to go through this yourself
slacks dead easy you can just create a
integration and get an access token
someone's already created a slack set of
nodes there are a few of them the one in
particular I'm using is here I just have
to configure that with the API key and
once that's connected when I talk to my
bot in a channel I get the message from
the slack API which has all this one
metadata that slack provides jumping
into bluemix we have the Watson
conversation service and that's really
cool service for creating chat BOTS you
can define basically describe how you
would like conversations to be
structured and what responses to give in
certain when certain things are detected
it works on a basic principle of you
define a bunch of intense basically what
someone might want to say or might want
to express so I've defined a turn-on
intent and you give it a bunch of
different ways of someone might express
that intent and what's and learns from
that so it's not a case of doing you
know exact pattern matching of things I
type Watson is actually learning and can
be trained to recognize a whole variety
of ways
someone might express the fact they want
the lights to turn on entities are the
things you talk about
so I've got some colors as entities and
devices as entities so that the
conversation service will recognize one
talking about something and then the
dialogue the UI gives you this big tree
structure of how you want conversations
to flow and there's a note for the
Watson conversation service you just
drop that in so at this point anything I
type and say to my chat bot will just
get past the conversation service and
I'll get a response back from the
conversation service a little bit of
finessing around the edges just to make
sure that because I would have a
conversation that when I say two things
to it it knows those two things are part
of the same conversation and then throw
in a bit of logic so that when the
conversation recognizes that I'm asking
it to turn it to a particular color I
can then clearly I can then punt a
message off to the Watson IOT platform
which then switching to the Raspberry Pi
I have a node read flow which is simply
that that's listening for the commands
from the Watson IOT platform reformats
it when it receives it and passes it to
the node we have for the sense app to
control it so that means you can't see
that live demo time everyone hold you my
don't hold your breath but so it means I
can say turn on the lights water
completely well that's how you turn them
off turn what off LEDs yeah now I know
it looks like I was mid conversation
with him which is why he turned them
blue without me asking them turn on
lights mm-hmm okay he seems to got stuck
on telling them blue turned red what you
want me to turn red oh I've got the
flying well but you get the idea it's
there we go
despite that that worked so you know
that's real
easy to do as many of you would have
noticed we have some sense hats and
raspberry pies at the back if you get
yourself registered and you know this
demo is ten minutes away from you guys
being able to do this for yourself let
me switch back and forgive me rusty I've
lost my phone I'm just going to turn off
my mobile data because I've done the
demo now and there's no point me
incurring and Wow it's meant to be free
but who knows with brexit and although
sorry mm-hmm it's fine um where are we
there we are so no dreads cool we've
we've used it for a lot of cool stuff
but there are other companies who are
using it for for real things some of the
feedback we sometimes get is yeah no
dreads nice for playing with but it's
not really suitable for production use
well you know here are some examples of
production use this is moment factory
another claim no come on play you're
gonna be awkward knowing you
the demo worked and then you know the
slides didn't um yeah okay so this is a
moment factory are a company who do for
very large scale lighting audio-visual
installations this is one they did in
Quebec in a coastal forest where you can
walk around this forest holding these
sticks with le dove in these these
sticks glowing orbs on the top but you
walk around you move yeah you can
interact with these with your glaring
sticks but this is no dread running on a
bunch of raspberry PI's in Tupperware
boxes strapped to these trees providing
all the sort of AV control as people
walk around this forest and that's yeah
really quite spectacular I'm going to
assume this one isn't in a play either
so that's this one is again moment
factory another project they've just
done in the last few weeks this is the
Jacques Cartier bridge in Montreal and
from sunset to son up the lighting on
all the girders of the bridge you can
sort hopefully you can just about make
out
it's got interactive lighting and that
lighting is based on traffic weather
social sentiment a whole bunch of data
about the city so that's where the
bridge comes to a comes to life
overnight and again it's no dread
controlling the lighting on that bridge
and that's quite cool right let's go
back
it's not just IOT you know if you look
at node-red clearly you can build any
sort of node application with it there's
a company called spirit AI and this is a
games company who create AI bots for
online games and one of their products
is this spirit Ally and it's an offering
for games manufacturers to embed in
their game
the monitors all of the chat transcripts
going on in the game to look for
behaviors in in the game that needs some
sort of moderation or needs some sorta
mated response whether that's things
like harassment threatening begging
whatever it might be so that's
essentially what what they have built
with spirit Ally and it is no dread
under the covers
so they've adopted node-red as the
tooling for for how the game analysts
the people who understand the sorts of
behaviors they need to monitor for their
game can very quickly set up the rules
around you know when you detect someone
begging in the game what actions should
you take or you know for your game what
sort of interaction constitutes
harassment whatever it might be so
that's a really interesting use case
very interesting from our perspective
because they've done some customizations
to node-red so they as I understand it
have a single node raid instance
handling 13 million chat entries a day
that's two thousand a second non-stop so
that's really interesting and we're
going to be getting some good feedback
from them about what they've had to what
they've changed in our runtime to to
achieve that sort of throughput in their
use case but again it's not just IOT
sometimes it is I see this is a UK
company interior automation who create
box this device that interfaces with
building management systems called
Moebius flow so they as it integrates
with building management systems and old
SCADA systems and it provides a much
more user-friendly environment for a
building owner to describe what sort of
Bay behaviors they want their building
management
to to do and if they've adopted node-red
to provide that automation and that
again that user-friendly UI to help the
building owner who's not a programmer
define the behaviors they want you know
what time do they want the lights coming
on you know if a motion sensor triggers
what what should happen all that sort of
behavior can be expressed by I mean and
this is what we see again and again with
no dread it's not just for developers
it's that intuitive UI is suitable for
lines of business you know domain
experts who can express the problem
they're trying to solve visually in a
node read flow without necessarily the
skills to write those individual lines
of code to do it for themselves operate
a charity who deliver aid using a
hovercraft the clue is very much in the
name but in hard-to-reach areas I think
in Bangladesh Ian's one region they they
work in they had a particular problem
where their hovercrafts which aren't new
being a charity you know they they sort
of used the equipment they have
available to them the hovercraft would
break down picks a part of the engine
was overheating that the any of the
hovercraft wasn't monitoring so one of
their people in their community just
over a weekend created a little
temperature probe and then they set up a
node red dashboard running on an Android
tablet so you can run node-red on
Android devices using the t-mac stuff
I've not tried it myself it feels wrong
but it works but in this instance with a
you know a $100 seven-inch tablet
they've got now a completely
customizable dashboard monitoring the
hovercraft so they can spot when it's
overheating or do whatever they need to
stop it breaking down and keep it in
service and it's not always about IOT
there's another example a project that
was done by some colleagues around a
proof of concept for a mobile banking
application in this instance they the
focus was on the mobile app so they use
node-red to create all the backend api's
and in fact they used nine node-red
applications running in bluemix
each the smallest size 256 Meg you know
tiny footprint each taking a different
part of the API and then they used our
API connect gateway at the top to handle
the security in the routing of requests
different parts and you know in the
testing they were doing for the
proof-of-concept they were handling 400
requests a second sustained yeah without
anything breaking a sweat and that was
really interesting from our perspective
because we weren't at all involved with
this and they came to us with some
feedback and you know we were aware of
some of the pain points around node-red
and it was really interesting to see how
this team had worked random themselves
how they had created their own DevOps
pipeline around you know saman hits
deploy how does that thing get pushed
into a production environment versioning
and all this other good stuff that we're
now thinking more about and then the
animatronic dinosaurs and I always pause
when I say that because of course it's
animatronic it's not a real dinosaur
this is in a theme park in the Saturn on
the Isle of Wight off the south coast of
the UK they had have had these dinosaurs
for many years there I believe they'd
lost so lost the relationship with the
Chinese manufacturer and the park owner
wanted to customize some of the
behaviors so the community banded
together and they created a Raspberry Pi
based controller for the dinosaurs and
they used node-red
to control the dinosaurs so now means
the park owner who is definitely not a
developer can define what sorts of
different behaviours they want the
dinosaurs to have when for example the
motion sensors get triggered and it's
really interesting when I'm recording
this saying to my son my six-year-old
look daddy's code is controlling that
dinosaur it's worked because my son is
currently running in the opposite
direction because there's a huge t-rex
roaring at him so there are lots of
people using node-red
for real things in production but you
know we recognize there are people who
aren't so sure about using their
derivative production and it's a funny
thing yeah a lot of it comes back to we
don't have a 1.0 version number yeah
from a technical point of view version
numbers are you know we follow semantic
versioning so we are quite happy
so incrementing the minor version
because we're we aren't breaking things
as we move forward we are you know
adding cool new features but without
that 1.0 label you know that there is an
important psychological fact about
having a 1.0 so in the last couple of
weeks we've actually now published what
our roadmap is to get to 1.0 and based
on the feedback from the community and
our own experiences these are the sorts
of themes we are thinking about moving
forward around the workflow and how we
can make developers more productive
using node-red
particularly there it's sort of
generously says modern development
practices you know there's there's some
key things missing if you've used
node-red collaboration making it easier
to work as a team with node-red
extensibility for those people who want
to embed node read and repurpose it for
other things making sure we've got the
right API is exposed so people can
extend it scaling so you know node-red
will scale horizontally very well but
there are some workflow challenges
around that and also you know we need to
do more to document the best practices
about how do you create a node read flow
that can scale because again it's that
funny criticism that says audio no read
can't scale well anyone in the room
could write a node application a java
application to go application that
cannot scale because you just you follow
all the worst practices and the same is
true of node read there will be flows
that scale and they'll be flows that
don't scale and when you think about
like the 12 factor apps stuff for cloud
one things we're looking at is well
what's what's the best practices to
apply those principles to when you're
working in node read an API stability so
for all the extension points and
everything we expose really giving the
confidence that those api's are then can
be developed against for the long term
so this is our roadmap to 1.0 trying to
express how those themes and how the
features which we've had on our Trello
board for you know for a long time you
know it's in its sintering when you have
a trailor board with a backlog of work
that's great for the people involved
day-to-day in the project because those
are the individual
what it lacks is that narrative of how
those individual items come together to
be meaningful and that's what we tried
to do with this roadmap so there's a
number of features we were looking at
through the rest of this year across a
set of releases that address a lot of
those pain points and a lot of those
themes the main big one we're starting
with is version control so today there
is no version control built into the
editor you kind of have to manually do
that yourself and yeah that kind of
sucks and yeah that is a very very
common as I'm sure you can appreciate a
bit of feedback so we are looking to
getting that version control integrated
into the editor so part of that is
moving away from your flow just being a
single file to this idea if your flow
being a project and your project can
contain your flow configuration
documentation like a readme settings
whatever it might be plus any other
assets that you need to version as part
of your flow and then within the editor
needs for the UI mock-ups that being
putting together have a git workflow
built into the editor so each time
you've hit deploy those are unstaged
changes once you're happy with what
you've got you can go in pick the
unstaged changes give a message and
commit them something has a copy and
paste is right in that slide the
challenges of how do you merge node read
flows which of these complex JSON
structures we already have a flow diff
tool that gives a much more structured
of you and again building that into the
version control to make it much more
natural that when you have to merge
inevitable conflicts with others it can
be done within the context of what a
flow Jason actually represents not the
individual bits of Jason and then it
will have the ability to roll back to
previous versions so if there is a
remote repository be able to push and
pull to that as well the next part is
about a library redesign so we already
have a library functionality in node-red
where you can save useful things locally
not part of your flow but that again
doesn't really work when you're
collaborating with others so we're going
to overhaul the lie
Bree so that you can do things like have
a a git repository that is a shared
library of assets within your team and
let you pull and push flows in and out
of that and again enabling some
interesting workflow around if you've
got a flow that your team is using and
someone updates that in the library
how can everyone's instance of that
library asset get updated seamlessly the
really big one the enable will enable
just so many other use cases of node-red
is splitting out the editor in the
runtime because today they're a
monolithic blob so we're gonna split out
the packaging of the two and in the
short term node-red will still be the
monolithic blob but it will be more of a
meta package that has pulled in these to
the editor package and the runtime
package but that starts enabling
scenarios like putting in custom code
between the editor and the runtime if
you need to do some sort of automated
manipulation of the flows before they're
given to the runtime perhaps you don't
even want to use our runtime you want to
use the editor to design some flow based
thing but it's not using a the node-red
runtime to actually implement that or
you don't have a whole fleet of runtimes
with a single editor and manage
horizontal scaling that way it just
enables so many different scenarios so
that that's gonna be a key one other
things thinking about scalability and
you know stability for those familiar
with node-red we already have decide you
of context so this is it's a runtime
state that can be stored within the flow
but at the moment if you restart
node-red that it gets wiped and if
you're running horizontally scaled
multiple instances that context is sort
of bound to each individual instance so
we're going to provide an appropriate
API so that context can be stored in an
external system like Redis at which
point you can start thinking more about
having multiple runtimes
with shared State another really
interesting one is making the routing
between nodes pluggable so that enables
a whole bunch of
different scenarios I mean some of the
ones we've requested we've had is have
much finer grained logging of the
messages going between nodes well you
know that's not they that particular
requirement had some very specific needs
so rather than build those needs into
node read if we make the message passing
a pluggable component you can insert
your own code in there to do whatever
you need it enables distributed node
read where the flow you design could
truly be actually these nodes run on my
Russ we PI down here and these nodes are
in bluemix and the what's no T platform
is inherently implicitly existing in
between those two sets of nodes and the
pluggable routing would just take care
of that and it what enables debugging
and that's another common question we
get is how do you debug node read flows
so we've started on the the UI prototype
for a flow debugger within node read
where you literally set breakpoints
within the flow and when a message
arrives there the runtime is paused and
you can then start examining the state
of the messages and different parts of
the system and that's possible once the
message routing is pluggable because
it's not functionality you would want
running in your production system so if
all of that's interesting to you sounds
interesting to you and you want to have
a play as I say we are on bluemix we're
on the Raspberry Pi presumably most you
already have node installed so we ran
NPM install away we have docker
containers we are we are versatile and
so the bluemix starter application on
github is another way to with its deploy
to bluemix button click that they'll
take you to bluemix and get it installed
for you for those who hadn't noticed my
colleague john is the back of the room
with a big stack of raspberry PI's and
sense hats which are there in exchange
for you guys if you sign up for a 30-day
free trial with bluemix and sign up to a
promo code that will get you an
additional 90 days access show john that
you've signed up and he'll give you a
Raspberry Pi in a sense out to go and
play with and take advantage of all the
things
the IBM platform provides you if you
want to find out more and there's plenty
more to be found out one of the new
things we started this year yeah as ever
with open source projects documentation
is is an area that can often lag behind
and you know I'm shame to omit node-red
is is much the same but we've started
the node-red cookbook so this is
creating a set of Brahe tasks simple
task oriented recipes for how do you do
basic things that hopefully you know
google start indexing and we can start
moving away from some of the questions
we get in the main list and the cookbook
is there to help but if people are
interested who have already played with
node-red and wants to start contributing
that's a great Avenue to start getting
involved and contributing to the
cookbook in our group we've created a
Coursera course developers guide to the
Internet of Things which makes a lot of
use of node-red
and the Watson IOT platform and the
routes we find cents hat so that's a
really course to play around with once
you've got hold of you sensor and
raspberry pi to learn more there's a
whole bunch of recipes for playing with
this stuff on IBM developerworks if you
want to play with the Watson cognitive
services there's the Watson developer
cloud provides a whole bunch of labs
across all of the services that are out
there and all their notes we've got
playing with Watson and in the IOT area
we've got our climate control sample
which again example using no dashboard
for for creating an IOT example with
simulation of devices and of course
Google's your friend there's plenty of
other online guides and for the for
those who read Japanese you can buy a
Japanese book about node-red and yeah
which is great it's cool and it's even
better than it's going to be a second
Japanese book by a different set of
authors coming out in a couple of months
so it turns out there's a very active
node-red community in Japan which is
excellent to see and in fact if you set
your browser locale to Japanese you will
get the UI in
japanese as they've contributed japanese
translations and we'll have chinese
translations very soon but again we're
looking for the community to help
contribute any translation you may want
to see node-red in so that's node-red
sort of introduction what we're up to
what others have done with node-red and
where we're headed
i'm around for the next hour in the cafe
area for office hours if you want come
have a chat and play with some of this
stuff do you know go and get your free
Raspberry Pi with John for a quick
signup to bluemix and play otherwise
that's me done thank you
[Applause]